welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
glass and Star Wars Episode three
Revenge of the Sith avenges the other
two prequels with a simple formula with
storing the look and feel of as much of
the original trilogy as possible letting
their MVPs obi-wan and Palpatine shine
doing hello
[Music]
and growing back a pair with some truly
dark pg-13 savagery days away from the
rise of Skywalker let us close out our
Star Wars rewatch series with the
strongest of the prequels Easter eggs
interesting visual details and hidden
ways these prequels culminated in the
most critical Star Wars development of
our generation radiata no he's not in
this video and before I begin quick
thanks to Marvel collect my Tops for
sponsoring this breakdown stick around
later for some details on a chance to
win some very cool prizes
okay the title Revenge of the Sith was
meant to mirror Return of the Jedi The
Revenge in question was hinted at by
Darth Maul back in Phantom Menace and
while the Sith Lord Sidious achieves us
revenge this synth have an inherent flaw
to worry about their own treachery Maul
was but one of a series of apprentices
that Sidious expends as he tries to
prevent himself from being betrayed the
way he betrayed his master eventually
the Sith he births in this film will get
revenge against him the opening battle
is one of the most thrilling sequences
of the trilogy with a 1 minute and 16
seconds the longest of any Star Wars
film to date notice one of the
projectiles that hits a republic ship is
a literal kitchen sink it's an in-joke
from the VFX artists that they threw
everything into the sequence including
the kitchen sink Ewan McGregor's obi-wan
Kenobi now more closely resembles Alec
Guinness his portrayal with similar hair
and vocal intonation and right away
there is a key moment that foreshadows
the coming conflict between him and
Anakin one is following the Jedi Code to
not let his emotions interfere but
Anakin's compassion but against that
code Palpatine will exploit this
compassion by answering Anakin's
nightmares about Padme death with an
empty promise to save her so they board
the command ship a sense of trap notice
that no trap is ever really revealed
during this rescue operation like they
find Palpatine surrounded as expected by
the separatists wears a trap it's a trap
whip but yes obi-wan instincts are right
the trap is a more broader plot laid out
by Palpatine to manipulate Anakin to
become its new apprentice during this we
meet General Grievous a kulish warlord
with cybernetic enhancements protecting
a damaged inner Anatomy causing this
cough
this sound effect was actually george
lucas's caught now one point is believed
Grievous had the midi-chlorian rich
blood of the late jedi sifo-dyas but dem
x-ray was revised he simply just learned
light skipper dueling from Dooku and is
not himself force sensitive when they
find Palpatine he slowly spins around in
his chair exactly how the emperor greets
Vader and returned the Jedi and like in
that film he presides over this duel and
goads a younger apprentice to kill his
former apprentice Anakin severs Dooku's
hands and Palpatine tells Anakin to
execute him without a trial doing in the
novelization in an early script draft
Dooku actually speaks up here he begs
Palpatine from solo please you promised
me immunity Christopher Lee expresses
this was just a great look of shock one
that will forever be on that severed
heads face and notice the ratchet on
Palpatine uses here he was too dangerous
to be kept alive leader mace windu will
echo this exact rationale to Anakin it's
justification to execute poverty he's
too dangerous to be left alive and so
the guilt that Anakin feels over this
rush to judgment helps lead him to make
that move later on in defense of
Palpatine
Anakin compassionately stops to save
obi-wan Anakin the snuke tight leave him
or we'll never make it
indeed time will prove that all three of
these men die by the hand of Anakin
slash Vader with Vader's death his own
doing taking on the Emperor's Sith
Lightning to save his son before I
continue thank you to marvel collect my
tops for sponsoring this episode unlock
a world where you can collect and trade
er Marvel characters and bring your
collection life by earning rewards by
completing sets trade and lower level or
duplicate cards to receive more special
limited ones much more the new
collectibles are released every day
Marvel collected by tops is available
both in the iTunes App Store and Google
Play Store worldwide and it's free to
download and free to play December is
Fan Appreciation Month and it's
celebrated in app tops Digital is giving
away one free collectible every day the
month for Marvel collect users to
collect and complete the search of 30
users can collect cards from days in the
month that have already passed even if
they didn't sign in that day so let's
check in on my progress I now have three
of the five I got Iron Man but still no
spider-man North Orient but I'll be
checking back in we're gonna get there
by completing these steps you can enter
for a chance to win $1,000 worth of
komm gift cards $250 Midtown comics
digital gift card or $100 worth of
in-app currency click on the link in
description to download marvel collects
app register a username and then collect
the 5 fan appreciation character cards
located in the free section of the pack
store once all five are collected you
will be eligible to win the giveaway and
be sure to follow at tops marble on
twitter and at tops digital on instagram
download marble collect my tops digital
trading card app to start collecting and
trading your favorite characters with
fans around the world the app is free to
play and new cards are released every
day download now from the link below in
the transport back to the Senate the
Millennium Falcon makes a little cameo
here and Palpatine explains what went
down
they killed Count Dooku but General
Grievous has escaped once again he
swiftly glosses over the fact that not
day but anakin alone executed Dooku a
nice cover there Padme tells Anakin that
she's pregnant
despite this happy news this
conversation is cast in deep shadow the
one dark spot in this whole bright sunny
Hall and again space is often masked and
shadow in this film making him look
increasingly sinister marking his
transition to the dark mask Spectre we
know he's headed toward later when they
made in her chamber you can see that
Padme now wears that necklace that
Anakin may purr and phantom menace she
also gets buried in it whoever arranged
that body should be fired Palpatine
extends his control over Anakin I need
you outside by calling him son
Palpatine is appealing to the same
desire for family that is driving Anakin
spheres about Padme and mirroring the
whole familial appeal that Luke will
make to Vader and return the Jedi by
repeatedly calling him father by
promoting Anakin as his personal
representative on the Jedi Council
puppet II knows that the council will
never make Anakin a master just at his
behest but he pushes Anakin into this
awkward position to drive a wedge
between him and the order you are on
this council but we do not grant you the
rank of Master what now despite his
recent obedience
Anakin just falls back into that same
defiance that he showed him as heck of
the clones why what
mannequins primary goal here is to keep
Padme and his unborn child safe why
would he be so salty about this career
snub anything being a Jedi Master and
the council would make it harder for him
to carry on as a family man clearly
Anakin is also motivated simply by
selfish power in Pride this fall isn't
solely due to his compassion he's also
just kind of a dick and when obi-wan
relays the council's directed to spy on
Palpatine for them they unwittingly
paint themselves as equally corrupt
politicians and Anakin's eyes as the
opening crawl hinted there are heroes on
both sides evil is everywhere also
there's a wooden behind Anakin you can
see and that's a space shuttle and as
the otis senses this coming darkness
notice this spent gesture as he runs his
hand over his head this is a direct
homage to akira kurosawa
the filmmaker perhaps most influential
on the original Star Wars films the shot
of Kambei Shimada in the seventh Samurai
moving on into the best scene of the
prequels Anakin and Palpatine at the
upper house soul who gained power I'm
afraid to lose it even the Jedi the Jedi
used their power for good what good is a
point of view any exact words here
parallel Obi Wan's frustrating council
to Luke and returned the Jedi so what I
told you was true from a certain point
of view a certain point of view obi-wan
in a way proves Palpatine right the
words of the Jedi can't always be
trusted you ever hear the tragedy of
Darth Plagueis the wise Darth Plagueis
was a Dark Lord of the Sith so powerful
and so wise he could use the Force to
influence the midi-chlorians to create
life
he could even keep the ones he cared
about from dying then his apprentice
killed him in his sleep ironic he could
save others from death but not himself
I love how Palpatine favors the end of
this story gloating as that bloodthirsty
apprentice in the legend the final Sith
in his own mind to climb to the top half
of the rule of two and hopefully never
have to worry about one of his
apprentices doing the same to him of
course he definitely should worry in the
water ballet that they're watching here
is called a squid Lake probably an
in-joke by the production crew do Swan
Lake it's actually a Mon Calamari
production with symmetrical choreography
two figures confronting and almost as if
in a duel of the things as Palpatine
offers this dark cautionary tale
centered all around with a rule of two
and we move on to the Wookiee planet
Kashyyyk the Republic 18 artsy light
walkers and a TA Peapod walkers are
actually forerunners of the Imperial 80s
tease that we saw in the original
trilogy and the juggernaut turbo tank if
you look at its body is actually based
on the designs of the 8080 or a tad
different preference suggesting that the
Empire would later convert to these
vehicles Yoda meets Chewbacca and some
wookie soldiers swing on to the droid
crafts with a Tarzan yell
there's actually a call back or call
forward whatever to Chuy's Tarzan yell
in Return of the Jedi on Utapau obi-wan
mounts of rectal named boga that's my
impression of him and he spies on the
separatist leaders strategizing long and
hard about the best way to keep this
element a surprise hello that actually
in an episode of the Clone Wars animated
series we find out that obi-wan was
really calling back a moment where
Grievous did this to him we wanted to
defeating grievous but not with a
lightsaber with a blaster slung
civilized obi-wan is calling back
calling forward his line in the first
film about lightsabers being an elegant
weapon little more civilized eh but now
we're in a world without honor we're
dirty tricks are the only way to win so
during all this Anakin walks in on
Palpatine watching Death Star porn and
probably this is the Jedi know your
power would be too strong to control
notice how it's dropped on strobe and
couldn't throw his identity is peeking
out as he finally reveals himself to
Anakin actually an early draft of the
script included Palpatine revealing that
he used Plagueis a--'s technique to
manipulate midi-chlorians to create
anakin in chinese womb saying i arranged
for the old conception you could almost
think of me as the old father George
Lucas removed it because he thought it
was too close to Vader's father reveal
and Empire but notice the art behind
them this is a freeze made by the
Massassi those were the ancient people
who built the temple on the Aven 4 and
it depicts the great hyperspace war
between the light side and the dark
sides of the force visiting Jedi would
have consider this piece a sign of
respect to them actually it's a Sith
artifact that Palpatine displays as a
statement of superiority he was under
their nose the whole time as Anakin
waits for the Jedi to arrest Palpatine
the blocking as the sequence intercuts
between him and Padme signals his
shifting perspective at first the
editing shows he and Padme facing each
other sitting Anakin facing right Padme
facing left but then they stand and go
to the windows facing each other across
the city with the eyelines
reverse now you could argue Anakin's
fall comes moments later but I would say
the fall begins with this single tier
Jedi Masters try to arrest Palpatine or
as he calls himself here the Senate and
genic but he reveals a hidden lightsaber
and wrexham that's pretty sad to see
expert duelists like Aegon co r SE c10
and Kit Fisto fooled like battle droids
though Palpatine is actually using three
advantages here that are a bit hard to
spot first his speed here just in
McDiarmid bigot of cool jump but in the
novelization his leap at them is
described as just a blur of red light
that they didn't see coming because they
weren't expecting the duel second notice
this sound he makes as he jumps this is
actually a Darkseid move called a forced
scream crazy devastating shockwave
Vader's oh is a poor scream because you
know we see it how it wrecks the droids
but finally Palpatine uses a more
aggressive lightsaber dueling style that
involves him using the blade like a
fencing foil and as this duel goes on
mace windu actually disarms them but
Palpatine hits him with some lightning
yeah after mace reflects the Lightning
Annika comes to his aid and cuts off
Windu's arm
[Music]
Palpatine promises to help Anakin save
Padme with an interesting line to choose
this one has achieved but if we work
together I notice she is a subtle I
shift when he says only one has achieved
now obviously that one person who
cheated death wasn't Plagueis Guzzi did
so it must have been cheap right so is
Palpatine immortal does this explain his
returning the rise of Skywalker we will
find out in 18 hours Palpatine names
andhave de
and states his goal will rule the galaxy
now you think that sentence was gonna
end with we shall have our revenge but
like the piece that they'll never have
the Sith will to never completely
achieve their revenge Anakin leads clone
troopers to the Jedi Temple killing
everyone even the younglings
[Music]
palpatine pulls a trigger the time has
come execute order 66 love that
Commander Cody just recognizes palps
melted face instead of saying like who
does one by one the Jedi go down
ki-adi-mundi blow Koon Aayla Secura Stas
Ali
but obi-wan and know to survive and I
love thinking about this moment from
Chuy's perspective
[Music]
Anakin catches up to the separatist
leaders on Mustafar
the lava covered planet originally
conceived by Ralph McQuarrie's concept
art for the original trilogy this
Massacre montage was inspired by the
famous baptism sequence from The
Godfather on which George Lucas worked
as an assistant editor in both scenes
the master manipulator ends the war by
coldly killing off all the rivals to his
power one by one Palpatine declares
himself the Emperor before the Senate
noticed Padma's hairpiece here has this
embossed wing pattern with the rebel
essential the deleted scene actually
features Bail Organa and Mon Mothma
forming the beginning to the Rebel
Alliance on Mustafar
Anakin makes Padme an offer together you
and I could rule the galaxy make things
the way we want them to be this is the
same offer that Vader will make to their
son Luke chewy and together we can rule
the galaxy as father and son a paranoid
insanity he forced chokes his pregnant
wife and so Anakin's rationale of doing
this all just to save Padme collapses he
is just a scared piece of [ __ ] obi-wan
arrives in he and Anakin engaged in the
legendary duel that their confrontation
and a new hope was a rematch of the
imagery is truly apocalyptic and hellish
that the world around them collapses
reflects how the dark side has already
won whether or not obi-wan is successful
parallel duel is waged between Yoda in
the Emperor set in the Senate chamber
which similarly collapses as Palpatine
dismantles it's cackling reflecting his
dismantling of democracy itself and it
ends in a draw
intubation
failed this moment onward failure will
actually be a key teaching tool for Yoda
remember your failure at the cave the
greatest teacher failure is what we want
Americans duel reaches its climax
it's our Veronica I have the high ground
you underestimate my power
well hey if you think about it obi-wan
was actually once in a similar situation
with Darth Maul had the high ground and
obi-wan used a similar front flip so
that is how he likely anticipated that
Anakin would try the same move here so
as Anakin wallows on the lava beach you
can see how his eyes transition within
one shot from normal to red completing
his transition obi-wan retrieves his
lightsaber setting up and handing it off
to Luke in a new hope now an inner
cutting sequence shows Anakin and Padme
limp bodies being brought into medical
bays Padme is bathed in light Anakin's
shrouded in shadow and while Padme
hairpiece earlier showed the rebel
signal an overhead shot of Anakin
reveals the Imperial crest for reasons
we can't explain we are losing her she's
lost the will to live yeah huh one
theory for this inexplicable nature of
her death is more manipulations by
Palpatine maybe he killed off Padme in
childbirth to trap Vader in perpetual
rage just think about how else would
Palpatine have known she died in this
moment he didn't have a role in it after
giving birth to Luke and Leia Padme
whispers her final words
[Music]
I know it's interesting how pony's final
line is a sentence completed by her
daughter's first chronological line in
row 1 how the iconic Vader mask lowers
on Anakin's face and I love the detail
of his first breath through the mask
exhaling and puffing back the smoke
Frankenstein no Bail Organa agrees to
take Leia and obi-wan will take Luke to
Tatooine and Organa orders his captain
Antilles the captain whom we see die in
a new hope as they take off on the tan
tip 4 at the protocol droids mind wiped
this memory wipe explains how Threepio
does not recognize anyone in the
original trilogy also notice this canted
force set was the only fully practical
set used for the film Oh green screen so
all that glossy VFX heavy look of the
prequels ends with a restoration to the
simple set that started at all Vader
joins the Emperor and Tarkin as they
oversee construction on the Death Star
and our final image sees obi-wan
delivering the baby Luke to Beru
and Owen as they watched the binary
sunset leading our future hero with just
enough hope to reverse assists revenge
with some day a Return of the Jedi huh
thank you for joining me on this Star
Wars rewatched series it's been so
rewarding to spend these weeks leading
up to episode 9 with in appreciation for
the journey that has led us here
if you're interested in years past we've
already covered the force awakens in the
last Jedi so bases officially covered
follow me on this we're going to twitter
at EA vas and subscribe to me rock stars
for breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for joining me and thanks for
being a good sport little sores banding
Master Skywalker there are too many of
them what are we going to do
[Music]